Hallo hallo BAU BAU!
It's time for FUWAMOCO Morning!
FUWAMOCO Morning hajimaru yo!
I'm not a chihuahua, I'm Fuwawa.
I'm not Fuwawa, I'm Mococo!
Together we are FUWAMOCO!
BAU BAU!
And today we are your hosts of FUWAMOCO Morning!
Morning!
Good morning Ruffians!
Good morning!
Thank you for joining us for our 140th episode today!
BAU BAU!
FUWAMOCO Morning is a short format morning show held every Friday, Wednesday and Monday aka FUWAMOCO!
Hosted by us.
FUWAMOCO!
Our aim is to bring a smile to your face and help you start your day off on the right paw!
Please tweet your thoughts with the hashtag #FWMCMORNING!
Let's all BAU BAU to a brand new FUWAMOCO Morning!
BAU BAU!
Oh my god, I'm a Ruffian's husband.
I'll do that for you.
Let's make it a great little camera cam.
I already know it's right before.
On the weekend, the first day of November too.
I want a big one's husband.
BAU BAU!
It's the start of a new month!
I totally really need Pero today.
Is that what you want?
Right away!
I don't want to see him first thing in the morning of a brand new month.
You wake up, open your eyes, Pero.
Right above you, smack dab in your face.
Pero.
Hi.
No.
FUWAMOCO-chan, was there a Pero Sighting or not?
There was.
There was!
Oh wait.
Wait, did you see Pero this time, Ruffians?
Let's take a look.
De-den!
BAU BAU!
Wait, wait!
Pero!
Koji Mischievous.
Singapore's Famous Merlin!
Merlin!
BAU BAU!
He was splashing around in the water and taking a drink!
Are you sure you want to do that?
I don't know.
That's not good.
It's not good, Pero.
It's really bad.
It's sort of embarrassing.
I don't know.
He ended up causing all that trouble.
Maybe Moco-chan will just have to go to Singapore and show him his top dog!
Hi!
That's so nice!
Is this a threat?
A threat to Pero?
It's a threat and also, you know, travel plans.
Maybe sometime around the end of the month.
You know?
Because you know there's an event going on.
Awesome!
Hi, Emi!
Just you wait for us, Pero, you know!
Just wait!
We'll take care of you, yeah!
Yeah, just have to wait a little bit, but... Moorlion's pretty cool.
Reminds me of the time that I became a moorlion.
Maybe we should fly out to Moco-chan, Merlion, huh?
No, I can't remember why, but I remember that it happened.
Yeah.
Well, we'll just have to go see the real Merlion soon, Moco-chan!
Yeah!
Oh, we're excited to go there!
See you soon, Merlion.
And I guess Pero.
BAU BAU!
Ruffians, it's a brand new month and you know in Halloween and everything there's a lot going on.
Yeah, a lot of excitement, a lot of new things.
And one of those things was, Halloween Senpai, she just had a brand new 3D concert.
J-Rap and Jigoku.
Woohoo!
We were there!
Bye!
FUWAMOCO Morning deshita.
Have a howl of a day!
Oh my gosh!
No!
I just danced.
I danced and danced.
Together with Rupo-chan and Karin-san.
We did our best together, all three of us!
My favorite part was, you know, the part where you kind of get to, you know...
Oshiri?
Otherwise I like the part that's like...
That part?
Oh!
I know that part!
Yeah!
I think Calli-senpai and I, we do the robot together!
We tried!
Calli-senpai!
Calli-senpai and I!
We tried doing, what's it?
Popping and walking!
Yeah, I do that a little bit too!
I don't think it really worked out for me, huh?
It was a lot of fun.
I did my best too!
It was so much fun singing all together.
Yeah!
And then we got the big hug from Calli-senpai!
Moco-chan, did you get electrocuted by Calli-senpai's hug or something?
I don't know!
BAU BAU!
FUWAMOCO Morning deshita.
Yeah.
She looks great now, right?
So different.
Yeah.
It was so easy, right?
Yeah!
I know.
And the songs that she sung and everything was so good.
It was so much fun.
And then also, Kelly-senpai revealed a brand new song called Flashback by P.E.S.S.
So please go check it out, Ruffians.
The visuals are very cute too.
It's really cute.
Apparently there's some things hidden in the visuals too, so...
Maybe I'll have to find the Ruffians.
BAU BAU!
Congratulations Calli-senpai!
You notice that Calli-senpai is a little taller now?
A bit taller You can't really notice here because she's sort of like BAU BAU!
We had so much fun!
Mom!
Shiori!
Yeah!
She had her big 3D Halloween too!
Did you check it out, Ruffians?
It was so cool!
So amazing!
We were there too!
Yeah, included!
Lots of novelty!
But then!
See what surprised us?
There's a brand new cover song called Dark Night!
Yeah!
BAU BAU!
That was so so amazing!
I wasn't expecting it.
I was like, what?
Shiori already had an amazing Halloween stream and then a coffee song too!
And this time you know, I feel like we got to hear a little bit of a different Shiori.
The chorus is very difficult.
Why?
We're just so happy to hear more singing from Shiori because we love Shiori singing voice too.
FUWAMOCO!
Ruffians, like you mentioned.
It's official.
It is November.
I'm not ready.
I feel like it's still May.
At least if it's not May, it's definitely September.
Definitely.
Definitely September.
It's November now.
Well, Ruffians, we wanted to say a big thank you to all the very creative Ruffians and hololisteners for all their music illustrations during holo-OCTOBER!
If we didn't have holo-OCTOBER, just combining hololive and October together, I still don't get this.
Wow, you know, it can be also holo-November, but holo-October!
It's actually an initiative started by Iofi-senpai, where every single day is a different theme.
Like a different prompt.
Yeah, a drawing prompt, a creative prompt.
And then you draw a picture of whatever comes to mind there.
Well, you see, I think most people draw, but you can do anything, you know, any sort of creative work.
FUWAMOCO Morning deshita.
The cheerleader day was very cute too!
The dedication that it takes to do so many days.
I know sometimes you see artists being like, I didn't get all the days or I could only complete this many days.
You're thinking about it wrong.
Not, I only was able to do this.
FUWAMOCO Morning deshita.
Thank you FUWAMOCO!
BAU BAU!
Wow!
It feels like about a year ago we were also talking about this!
But!
There's been some exciting updates!
Yeah!
Some exciting updates!
Wow, it was just announced that back in Tokyo Station, starting November 14th, there will be a pop-up store back in the Tokyo County again!
BAU BAU!
FUWAMOCO!
Look!
And everybody's in these cute outfits!
They should attend an official shop!
Tokyo Character Street is very famous!
You know, lots of different characters have their stores in there.
Sanrio Hello Kitty.
Gudetama.
Those kind of big characters, they're all there!
That's a big deal!
You know, right there with the big ones.
And you know, you can see a bunch of us right here!
ID JPEH.
Shiori!
You know, in the original station attendant outfit.
Right?
So so cute!
Kaya-senpai is still very very cool!
Yeah!
But there'll be lots of merch limited to the location being on sale there!
So we hope that you'll go check it out!
There'll also be some in-store announcements by the resident newbie!
Nodoka!
Does she really count as a newbie?
She called herself a newbie!
I don't know about that though.
You see Biboo,
Where are you, Biboo?
So fun!
We are both short, but... Biboo!
What?
It's a little bit of a darker Biboo.
Yeah.
But we have to go to the store.
Well, right now, you know, it's just open.
It's gonna be pretty busy.
So you need to reserve an entry ticket
For the first few days here, in case you didn't know, Ruffians, often for events like this, even if it's buying merch, you need an entry ticket.
You need an entry ticket.
You just need to reserve it in advance.
Just remember that sometimes, even if you want to go to a store to buy some merchandise, if it's busy, you might need to get a special reservation ticket.
So please make sure you check out everything before you like... Okay!
Oh my god!
Tokyo Station!
We don't want you to be disappointed!
Although, you know, after the first little bit, it might be a bit...
Please check it out, Ruffians!
There'll be more updates, I think, coming soon, too!
There's lots of cute words, so please check it out!
BAU BAU!
And a continuation of the exciting updates!
For Ruffians who really enjoy it and recommend it, we have this FUWAMOCO style blanket!
We saw you noticed so many Ruffians, so many listeners saying,
I want the cloak for myself.
And now you know it's November, it's officially starting to get warm.
Have you turned on your heating yet, Ruffians?
Maybe you know you can have a little bit of a revelation in comfort and warmth with this Lobesta Cloak Style Blanket.
It's a revelation to comfort and warmth, okay?
So please go check it out.
I'm sure you'll be able to get lots of use out of it throughout this colder time period.
And then, you know, before you know it, you'll start feeling warmer.
Did you notice what Ina-senpai is saying?
What is she saying, Moco-chan?
In a matching style.
In a... Cause it's Ina-senpai!
I see that there.
I think she could do better.
FUWAMOCO Please check it out, Ruffians!
You can find it on the online official hololive shopbooking!
BAU BAU!
Well, Ruffians... It's been a little while... But Ruffians... We actually have... A bit of a confession for you!
Compassion!
Ruffians!
Not a misunderstanding, okay?
Well, there's been something that's kind of been weighing on us for quite a while.
Yeah.
A few months here.
You know, we're senpai now.
We're senpai now!
You know, just this debut.
Everyone's so unique.
They all have their own member colors.
Red.
Green.
Yellow.
When we collab with Ame-senpai, you know, we said that we're so happy because you know, all the Holo-EN blondes are together!
Right!
We're all together for the first time Holo-EN blondes!
Yeah!
BAU BAU!
And you know, Ame-senpai, we isn't GG blonde though.
Yeah!
Have a howl of a day!
And then... Yeah, I guess if Ame-senpai's saying Gigi's blonde, then yeah!
We've been a bit in crisis.
Yeah!
Is Gigi blonde?
Gigi's blonde!
Have we been excluding her?
How can we do that as senpai?
Right!
Oh my gosh, what can we do?
What should we do?
So we've been kind of living in hiding.
Right, in crisis.
Is Gigi blonde and we just misunderstood the whole entire time?
But Ruffians, we asked the source.
We finally did it.
We got to the bottom of it.
We got the words and we asked Gigi herself.
Gigi, are you blonde?
She goes...
No.
Gigi's the blood mafia!
She has brown hair!
Yeah!
It's okay!
We were horrible selves but it's a good way to spend our time!
Yeah, she has brown hair with lighter brown hair!
Yeah, it's not blonde!
That's the confession.
We were in turmoil forever.
We can live happier days knowing that Gigi is in fact not blonde.
We weren't excluding her now.
BAU BAU!
We just need to ask questions.
Yes, it never hurts to ask questions, right?
You know, we had the haunting investigation.
Or maybe there is a couple other investigations going down, huh?
Case solved.
Case closed.
BAU BAU!
Ruffians!
As you might know, just yesterday... Was it yesterday?
A day ago, some time ago.
Time!
At the end of the month, we said goodbye to our most favorite place ever.
Akihabara MisDo.
BAU BAU!
We are really happy that we could be able to say goodbye all together with you, Ruffians.
It was really, really special to us.
Really important.
That we could kind of have this moment to say goodbye.
Yeah, be able to spend the time, you know.
The last hour that Akihabara Mizuho was open.
Yeah, you know.
But we wanted to say a big thank you to the super fans!
You're super standing back up here!
Right in front of the window on the second floor overlooking Akihabara's main street.
It's perfect.
FUWAMOCO Morning deshita.
Have a howl of a day!
It's still really hard for us, you know, we're trying our best to hold back our tears too, but just thank you Ruffians for being there with us during that moment.
And you know, also to all the Ruffians that were able to visit, you know, have pon-de-ring dinner over at Akihabara just cause we have many many times before.
It really meant so much to us, so thank you Ruffians.
And also a big, big thank you to Akihabara for being such a special place to us.
And for all of Akihabara for 52 years.
BAU BAU!
It was very special.
There's other locations too, so for any love fans that are like, no I didn't get to eat a pon-de-ring, no!
You still can!
It's just one location in a chain store, that's it.
That's it.
Yeah, but it was very special.
Very special.
Very place, yes.
BAU BAU!
Today is also a day where we got to say a little bit of a... See you soon!
In case you didn't know, today is the last day before FUWAMOCO Morning goes into a bit of a hibernation period.
It'll be back soon, but the reason why it's going into hibernation is so that we can focus more on our health and other exciting things to do!
In case you didn't know, Ruffians, it was busy when we debuted.
But since then, it's been less and less and less and less sleep.
I know.
If we continue like this, there's probably not going to be any sleep soon.
So today is going to be the last episode of FUWAMOCO Morning for 2024!
But Ruffians!
You know... Oh that's great!
Now I don't need to wake up early to go back to sleep!
No!
No, no, no, Ruffians!
No, you just can't do that, you know!
We have some do's and don'ts for you, okay?
Do wake up early!
You know, early in the morning!
Yes!
Don't go back to sleep!
No!
Do!
Keep your schedule!
Keep your schedule, Ruffians!
You always wake up early.
Why are you making that face, huh?
Go on walks, okay, Ruffians?
Sleep is good, but it means you have to go to sleep earlier and then wake up.
Go to sleep early and wake up early.
And you know, let us know how your work went using the hashtag #FWMCMORNING.
What was your best shot from that work, you know?
You know, we still want you starting your day off on the right paw.
So, you know, continue all these great habits you've made together with us here, okay, Ruffians?
You know, and maybe if you're feeling a little bit lonely like, ah, today's another morning, but FUWAMOCO's not here and it's a Wednesday!
You know, why don't you check out maybe some of the past FUWAMOCO Mornings?
You know!
There's 140 of them.
I'm sure there's probably at least a couple that you haven't been able to check out.
Right, right.
But maybe you've already forgotten.
Well, well being.
We hope that you know you'll still have a very special part of your day ready for FUWAMOCO Morning.
And that you know, you know that we're always here protecting your smile and we're gonna do our best at all the things we have planned for you!
So, bye!
Don't call this the last FUWAMOCO Morning.
It's not the last FUWAMOCO Morning.
Okay, okay.
We're back!
Look at the picture here.
It says back.
March 10th at 8am.
PT information.
Yeah.
Right there.
FUWAMOCO!
We are not going on hiatus!
No!
What the heck!
We will still be streaming!
Yes!
Multiple times a week!
If you say those things, we're basically gonna track you down, okay?
We're working even harder than ever, okay?
It's not a break!
It's just a hibernation, you know?
Just like the bear goes to hibernate, you know?
FUWAMOCO Morning!
It might look like sleep, it might look like a break, but he's working hard, he's hibernating!
That would be nice, huh?
Because hibernation FUWAMOCO Morning!
FUWAMOCO Morning.
Not FUWAMOCO.
No.
Yeah.
Got it.
Got it, Ruffians.
No misunderstanding!
Oh, I'll just make this my misunderstanding.
No.
No!
Kill Ruffians!
Got it!
Otherwise we're gonna have to track you down.
You wouldn't want that!
Put it in the closet when I come out.
No!
BAU BAU!
We'll see you again soon, Ruffians!
On March 10th at 8am PT.
It's not a break.
BAU BAU!
Well, Ruffians, you know... It's gonna be a little while until the next FUWAMOCO Morning, so... We wanted to share something extra special with you today.
Is that okay?
We have a little bit of a letter for you today!
We wanted to say something.
We know.
Since this is the last FUWAMOCO Morning until 2025, we wanted to let you know just how important FUWAMOCO Morning has been to us.
You know, FUWAMOCO Morning has been a very special stream that we've been continuing three times a week since we debuted!
With only a few missed episodes, you know,
Having yakiniku with Suisei-senpai or you know, being too close to one million is heroic!
When we were moving to Japan, stuff like that.
Right?
And it's meant so so much to us to be able to start our day together with you!
And to know that we can send you off on the right paw, the best paw!
No matter how hard your day was gonna
Maybe B?
I love B!
Yeah, that's what we always wanted, you know?
So, you know, for it to go into hibernation like this, and not be able to have that time with you, it's a really hard decision for us.
You know, we don't really want that too, but sometimes hard decisions need to be made, you know?
But!
Despite that, we'll make sure that we're our best selves!
We'll remember what's important!
We'll work hard even if it means that we won't be able to see your sleepy face as you're just getting up three times a week.
For just a little bit.
For a little bit, okay?
Just a little bit, okay?
You know, BAU time is rough.
So, we'll be back here again really, really soon!
Before you know it, Ruffians!
Yeah, so we'll see you again on March 10th at 8AM PT, okay?
FUWAMOCO Morning!
BAU BAU!
Thank you Ruffians!
We will go over our schedule very soon because you will be seeing us in only a few hours from now.
But before that!
We have the Doggie of the Day!
Let's check out our Doggie of the Day!
This Doggie of the Day is... Delphine!
BAU BAU!
I'm so happy!
Look at that big smile!
Yeah, I know!
I'd be so happy to be there by your side!
She looks so sweet!
I'm gonna get some head pats.
FUWAMOCO Morning!
She's powerful.
Powered by sweetness.
And I can see just how incredibly happy she is to be a part of your family.
You know the BAU BAU wants to walk together with you.
Take some coffee naps right beside you too.
She never invades your personal space.
No!
But, as for if she's fluffy or fuzzy, I would say fluffy.
She's fuzzy!
Kind of fuzzy.
Fuzzy.
Fluffy and fuzzy.
Yeah, a bit of both.
BAU BAU!
Wow, next Ruffian!
This is only one of your walks.
I'm expecting lots more walks soon!
Okay!
Well, let's check out your walk.
Hi!
On today, I went on a walk.
We have!
De-den!
FUWAMOCO!
So many flowers!
Two loops!
I stopped because I didn't want to be with so many flowers!
I stopped because I was trying to think of what kind of flowers it is.
This is a little white back car.
It's so pretty!
Two loops high!
Oh my gosh, look at the sun rays there.
The sky, the mountains, all the colors.
Beautiful.
The smell!
But, Ruffians, you know, it's really really important to go outside and explore.
Even if you know, you're like, well there's no tulips on the way, I'm gonna walk around.
You never know there might be at least one, or even something more beautiful.
You know, if you don't go out and explore, you know, you might miss some amazing things.
You know, beautiful sights, maybe opportunities too!
You don't even know what you're missing!
You know, there really are only so many seasons you can enjoy, so we really hope that you'll continue to take walks, okay, Ruffians?
Especially because it's chilly now.
But make sure you're warm.
Got it?
BAU BAU!
You're gonna use this Ruffian's walk as a wallpaper?
I guess that makes sense.
It's so beautiful.
BAU BAU!
Next we have a Question of the Day.
We have De-den!
Good morning FUWAMOCO!
FUWAMOCO Morning is going into hibernation.
But do you have any tips or advices to help us start our day off on the right paw until it's back?
Maybe something you do in your morning routine?
Looking forward to sharing more mornings together in March.
BAU BAU!
It's really important to have Ruffians.
You know, I feel like you can get so much done if you just go, well, this is what I do every day at this time.
Yeah.
It's really important.
So if you put something on the, I don't want to do that, in the morning routine, then suddenly, you know, it's done.
Stretches, right?
Stretches are so important.
Ruffians!
Have you thought of the last time you stretched?
Not just like stretched like in your chair.
That doesn't count.
No.
Go on the floor!
Or on your bed!
Five years ago!
I think it's time.
Right?
I think it's time, Robin!
You can do it!
Yeah!
You can get the extreme stretches in there!
Yes!
And then you know the morning routine too.
You can start your day off on the right paw.
I know, but things you know like getting a comfy sleep.
Healthy breakfast.
Yes!
It's very easy and very important.
I see a lot of people being like, oh but if I eat breakfast in the morning I feel nauseous.
That's because you're not eating breakfast.
You know, just making yourself the best version of you before you head out is the best thing you can do, I think, you know?
Prepare yourself in so many ways for your day!
Miko, you can do it, okay?
We'll feel you!
Miko's proud, okay?
Even more proud!
Even more proud, okay?
BAU BAU!
Thank you so so much for always being such a special part of FUWAMOCO Morning here with us, Ruffians!
I know like we mentioned, FUWAMOCO Morning is going to be heading into a hibernation period until it's back, March 10th at 8AM PT!
We're not going anywhere!
Okay, Ruffians.
Thank you so so much.
We'll still be looking at the hashtag!
Hashtag FWMCMORNING!
So please send us your submissions, you know, the vlogs that you go on, any cute dogs you might see, and maybe any sightings of Pero you happen upon to your baby.
BAU BAU!
Thank you, Ruffians!
Let's take a look at our schedule here.
Yeah, our schedule!
Actually, wait wait wait.
It's not exactly our next stream, but...
We will have it on our next schedule but we are still gonna be doing our 3D trick-or-treating
And we would like you to join us for Trick-or-Treat in November again.
Stay tuned for more FUWAMOCO!
BAU BAU!
I can't keep the Ruffians up past midnight and then ask you to wake up at 8am.
We're thinking about you, okay?
That's why!
For the schedule. Our next stream coming up at 6pm PT today. We're gonna be playing some Donkey Kong Country. It's been a long time. I'm really looking forward to getting back into it. To jumping over this over that and screaming a bunch too. So please join us for the chaos, Ruffians. And then on Saturday we're gonna be back to some Minecraft.
It's been a little while, but it's just me, Moco-chan, and I, and you!
Exploring Minecraft, learning all about Minecraft together.
So we hope to see you there, Ruffians!
Yeah, try to find Fuwawa's buried treasure.
Yeah.
Remember that in your own heart.
BAU BAU!
And for the Ruffians joining us in the R-Class today, your FUWAMOCODEword is... BAU BAU!
Be back soon!
BAU BAU!
Thank you so much, Ruffians!
Thank you, Ruffians.
Thank you for joining us today for FUWAMOCO Morning!
It'll be a little while until we spend our next morning together.
But we'll be back really soon, okay?
Before you know it!
Before we say BAU BAU for now, I'd like to shout out to some of our Extra Special Ruffians today!
Super SSG!
BAU BAU!
FIMO!
FUWAMOCO Morning!
It's time for FUWAMOCO!
Sumichihana!
BAU BAU!
Samuel-chan!
The library!
BAU BAU!
Noshio!
Hokusai!
BAU BAU!
And you-chan!
You're our Extra Special Ruffians!
Always!
Got it!
BAU BAU!
We hope you have a howl of a day everyday!
This was today's FUWAMOCO Morning!
FUWAMOCO Morning deshita!